des habitants curieux comme intrigué par
ce qu'ils ont devant leurs yeux
c'est sur ce parking de Kiev qu'un
missile russe détruit par la défense
entière
ukrainienne a fini sa course
appelée en urgence les propriétaires ne
peuvent que constater les dégâts
les gens du garage m'ont appelé ils
m'ont dit qu'une requête était tombée ou
plutôt ce qu'il en reste ils m'ont dit
que tout était en feu et qu'il fallait
que je vienne vite voir la voiture je
l'ai vu elle est très endommagée
un peu plus loin les habitants de cet
immeuble résidentiel eux aussi ont été
surpris dès les premières lueurs du jour
je me suis réveillé en sautant de mon
lit à côté de moi il y a un jardin
d'enfants beaucoup de fenêtres ont été
brisées
c'est un drone ou quelque chose comme ça
petit dans la matinée pour promener mon
chien il y avait des ambulances un peu
partout
l'Ukraine Lassure elle a abattu 29 des
30 missiles de croisière tirés par
Moscou ainsi que quatre drones le seul
missile non intercepté à toucher la
ville d'Odessa situé sur la mer Noire
dans le sud du pays sur place une
personne a été tuée et deux autres
blessés
depuis le début du mois de mai c'est
déjà la neuvième salvereuse de ce type
des frappes qui interviennent pendant la
visite à Kiev d'un haut responsable
chinois chargé par Pékin de trouver une
solution au conflit